great to be back in person i think this
is the my first in person in addition to
the class lectures i just gave in the
winter quarter at celtic
so yeah great to see everyone in person
and
yeah i think
i want this to be very interactive you
know this is what i've missed
with the zoom talks like just seeing
people getting this real-time feedback
and
so feel free to interrupt me anytime
great um so yeah as you'll see from the
title it's a broad topic right so we
want to do robot learning
and how do we have generalizable robust
learning algorithms for this
you know in some sense robotics is
like almost a moonshot challenge for
many of the learning algorithms because
we're going from passive learning to
interactive learning we have safety
stability all these requirements
and so many of the deep learning methods
are brittle and they fail right so they
wouldn't hold up
in these real world conditions and the
other aspect is sample efficiency you
know you need to adapt quickly in real
world conditions
so how do we design better foundations
for learning and with the view of
robotics applications so today i'll give
you some of those foundational tools and
show you some applications to robotics
and many of them are ongoing right so i
think i'll also talk about some advances
in computer vision like self-supervised
learning i think are hugely important
for robotics but we haven't taken it all
the way there so there's a lot of
potential
for these different areas to come
together
yeah so when i think about uh
generalizable ai right so
generalization can work in so many ways
uh you know we have the standard
definition
of training and test distributions being
the same and can it generalize right
that's how we get the
theory of generalization but in real
world you would need to go much beyond
what i call extrapolation like into
scenarios that you've never encountered
before and test distribution being
significantly different from training
and so that's where you know in our
brain we have the framework of system
one and system two and the system two is
the one that's kind of helping us
extrapolate you know think rationally
maybe have simple grounding and
you know through that have causal
thinking and extrapolate to new
scenarios
and so how do we enable that in ai
so i
see three facets as being important
right so we need very robust uh
representation learning
and we humans are great at this you know
as infants we are doing self-supervised
learning we are you know able to do this
foreground background
separation very effectively and with
that object-centric uh
representations right we can
build the view of the world and
move around that very effectively and
that comes also with interactions right
you you know if you've seen babies learn
they're always touching they're moving
they're moving their heads you know
understanding the occlusions
so interaction is a key and and that's
why i i love robotics although i've
you know i didn't grow up learning
robotics in my grad school because of
this interactive aspects you know when
we
we can have better data we can you know
go
look for
challenging scenarios with passive data
sets that wouldn't be possible
and the last aspect and perhaps the
hardest one is compositionality and with
that being able to reason about unseen
scenarios um you know you could also
call that zero shot generalization so
you have not
you know seen uh
now
you know you haven't seen a unicorn but
you've seen a horse can you still reason
that it's similar to a horse but it's
different right in terms of you know
it's horn
so those aspects
require right what we think of our
system too because you
not just have a representation you're
able to compose and generate
and reason about scenarios that were
never present in training
yeah so to begin with the foundation
that i want to provide is what i call
physics ml models you know broadly when
we think about physical systems uh uh
what are some challenges we want to
solve in terms of complex multi-scale
behavior
right and how
we can then use it in
applications like the climate sciences
that marco just said
but also why is that useful for robotics
um so these are aspects i'll
address
and uh to me like
why we need to rethink uh the use of
machine learning in these scenarios is
because our physical world is continuous
right so many times we discretize
because it's convenient you know even
now when we think about state action
spaces we try to discretize right and
you know traditionally it's done in a
hand engineered manner and then from
those abstractions we try to do low
level mid-level and low-level control
but what if we could like come up with
machine learning surrogates that can
simulate these real-world phenomena very
effectively
and do it at different conditions right
because then that becomes uh a great
tool both for
right like design like you know how to
design the right control for different
physical conditions
but ideally ultimately for real-time
control as well because if you can
generate for instance how turbulence is
going to evolve uh very fast then you
can
handle the turbulent conditions very
effectively um yeah so in you know these
uh what the lens we want to approach
this is through partial differential
equations right that's a broad
uh
class of uh phenomena that can be
represented from materials
right like material properties like
elasticity and these you can define it
through newton's laws of motion and you
can
turn that into pdes as well as fluid
dynamics in most of these cases
the equations themselves are quite
simple but the phenomena they represent
is right highly multiscale possibly even
chaotic
so how do we
right have machine learning methods that
can
simulate this in a faithful manner
and that's a challenge
so as one example we're looking in the
uh right context of control uh is
right i mean ultimately you want to be
able to fly drones in
turbulent conditions but as a starting
step we can think about testing airfoils
in
these turbulent wind conditions
right and uh here there are you know we
we have our navier stokes we can
write model fluid dynamics reasonably
well with navier stokes right uh but uh
we would still need to figure out what
are the reynolds numbers and how that is
evolving
but the challenge is these simulators
tend to be very slow so you cannot have
that be real time uh so how can we use
now machine learning instead to replace
the traditional simulators
and then there is also the challenge
that you may not be
observing the whole force field i mean
in this example here you have the
airfoil you you know usually have a few
sensors placed along the boundary or
somewhere you know you don't have the
full force field so there is this
problem that it is uh there are hidden
states this is partially observed
control system a dynamical system
so we also have the additional challenge
that uh we need to estimate the state
and we could use these uh partial
differential equations to do the state
estimation and so that's what is
traditionally done uh it's called a pde
observer method
so where we essentially do the pde
backstepping to
do the state estimation so meaning if
you have a sensor at the boundary right
and given those
that observation on the boundary you try
to propagate that
through
right the
partial differential equation stepping
and with that get an estimate of the
full state
so this is a classical method but the
main problem is it's too slow and not
real time right so because you have to
do it you have to do the state
estimation fast enough because you have
to control
once you have this uh state estimation
and keep updating it right with the
new measurements so
so this is one problem we wanted to
you know
use you can describe this pde observer
the state estimation problem as a
partial differential equation uh but it
is slow to solve with uh
you know standard numerical methods
and so one application where you can use
machine learning if you can emulate
these partial differential equation
solutions effectively
so let me now give you some
aspects of why we need a new foundation
in terms of machine learning for such
systems
so the main aspect is if you look at
standard neural networks they're very
much dependent on the resolution of the
input
right so you know you have an input
image of a certain resolution you can
train it very well it'll work well in
that resolution on the other hand you
change the resolution right you may get
very different answers
but this is a huge problem for
solving partial differential equations
because they tend to be highly
multiscale you know you need to go to
very fine scale and capture
the fine scales to be able to
solve the system effectively
but you know if you want to use a
standard
pde solver right it has a lot of
flexibility you can change the grid
right in the airfoil like you know there
are different grids available especially
near the sharp
edges you want more discretization
because there you could even have
discontinuities so those aspects right
of
being having the flexibility of having
different
kinds of grids and different resolutions
so you can do that with a standard pde
solver using numerical methods so how do
we try to do the same with also a
machine learning method so you let's say
you have a trained neural network but it
should be flexible enough to give you
the right amount
yeah so we have now you know that's our
requirement right so we with standard
neural networks we would have to retrain
the network with every resolution and
every a different grid uh but
you know by doing so it's also
overfitting to only potentially that
resolution and not capturing the
underlying continuous phenomena very
well
instead if
we have an approach that is resolution
and grid invariant
we can hopefully capture the underlying
phenomena better and that's why we call
it the operator because ultimately uh
what we think of solutions as partial
differential equations are operators
right because you have an input function
space and an output function space the
input function space could be the
right the initial and boundary
conditions like you saw in the previous
slide and the output is the solution
function space so these are
right continuous spaces and we don't
want to limit to one discretization
and so that's the requirement now the
question is how do we go about building
one
oh yeah i forgot this doesn't work
um yeah so
you know the principle is quite simple
and similar to how you would do it in a
standard neural network right you would
have some linear operation in a standard
network that can be if it's mlp just a
matrix multiplication of a fixed size
right our convolution is also a linear
operation and then non-linearity like
relu or other ones
so we want a similar expressivity but
now in function spaces
and so for that uh we what we want to
have is a linear operator right so
so this one should be able to accept any
discretization of initial and boundary
conditions
so if you can learn a linear operator
you know in certain layers of the
network compose it with non-linearity
then we can have a universal
approximator
for
operators
right so i haven't still told you how
but this is a natural one start with a
linear operator compose it with
non-linearities and
you get an expressive model
so one natural
design for this linear operator
is thinking about what is the solution
structure for linear partial
differential equations
so if you recall your pde class right
that is the green's function and its
convolution with the green's function
right so any linear partial differential
equation can be
described in that manner okay and forget
that
and so for instance this is the famous
heat diffusion equation there in fact
you analytically know the kernel or the
green's function and you can integrate
through that
so you would have done this in your pde
course
right but in general for non-linear pdes
we wouldn't necessarily have this form
right so but we can now ask if i can
have layers that can solve this
integral operator which is nothing but a
continuous convolution so instead of
like small convolutional filters that
are
working on a discrete grid right at one
fixed resolution we want to learn
kernels that can
essentially do the convolution in the
continuous domain
and now the question is how do we
approximate this well because if we can
design now layers that can do such
integral operators effectively
then we can compose them with
non-linearity and get an expressive
model
and so that's where we resort to fourier
transform you could also use other bases
right fourier is one example of a
basis change because you could
now
approximate
this convolution as multiplication in
the fourier domain so this is a standard
approach and especially this is useful
for many scientific applications because
this is global so if you do small
convolutional filters in your cnns
they're very local right they're you
know mostly used for edge detection
locally but if it's like fluid flow you
need
a global phenomena and fourier transform
can capture global correlations well so
that's another benefit
and we also know like these fluid
dynamics are well described in the
frequency domain right we talk about how
the
energy
decays uh with respect to different wave
numbers so it's a good inductive bias
but it also makes it convenient
to
learn
the mixing weights in the frequency
domain so what we are doing is
doing the fourier transform learning
mixing weights in the
fourier domain and um this is like a
regularization we only keep some low
frequency components
when we are doing the inverse fourier
transform
but we are composing it with
non-linearity so it still has
expressivity right so you want to
trade off like how much you want to
regularize and how much expressivity you
want to have
but with this what we are able to do is
we have a network that can work at
different resolutions
because you can like you know do the
four-year representation at any
resolution right so that's the benefit
of this method
that it is flexible you know even if you
learnt in one resolution
you can generalize and ask evaluate
a different resolution grid
any questions here
and for example fluids you're interested
actually the global information that's
what you said to me i don't see it right
away i would say especially in these
kind of physics
phenomena you're always interested in
local information and so generally i'm a
bit surprised that like this four-year
structure would always you have a very
very large domain
there's like a lot of information of the
whole domain and if you in the four-year
transform right and but you're only
interested in some local shock for
example it seems a bit tricky right but
once you know where the shock is it's
local right but determining where the
shocks will happen for instance is
global and and shocks happen in certain
way you know reynolds numbers in others
it could be smooth um yes i mean you
know like at any point of time it could
be local but if you want to do a long
trajectory prediction
right you want to propagate the
information globally
and if you did like convolutional
networks the receptive fields are too
small it you know doesn't capture it
very well
and the other of course drawback is it's
tied to that resolution and doesn't
generalize very well to a different one
that's a good point
anyone else
yeah so this is uh right uh our
model proposal where uh we're doing you
know quite simple operations these are
also fast operations with fourier
transform and so by doing frequency
domain processing uh
we are able to
uh for instance train on
lower resolution data sorry
and then directly evaluate it on higher
resolution data and do that pretty
accurately
of course you want to have some minimum
resolution right it can't be
too coarser resolution because if you're
not capturing enough of
the
frequency structure you wouldn't be able
to do it uh but as long as it's uh you
know
good enough resolution you can also
do zero shot super resolution and so
that's a nice thing about the
flexibility of these methods
yes so back to our pde observer
you know in this project what we asked
was how we can use this fno to
emulate the pde observer
uh we have uh
you know the main idea is as a state
estimation it's a recurrent network
right so you know we can also do
like a standard recurrent neural network
but the benefit here is this is done
in a resolution invariant manner so
captures the turbulence much better
and in than a standard rnn
um yeah some preliminary results i
should say we haven't still put this
together with the controller but for
state estimation we see uh promising
results so this is a
the conventional
observer and then we have the fno
emulate this and get about
2 000 times speed up so you know now
i think there are many steps to see how
we can you know put that with the
controller and do that in the airfoil
system that i
just described
so even though we haven't run that we
did a simpler
model that does use a
four-year basis to do a model-based
reinforcement learning scheme in that
airfoil setup that i mentioned and we've
already seen promising results here to
be able to stabilize it uh really well
right so it has
you know much even lower variance of
stabilization both the mean and variance
you see are the lowest
and do it with much fewer samples
compared to
standard methods you know like model uh
free rl and also model based if you do
like
right standard lstm that's too many
parameters to learn
so that's i think
is another benefit of these methods by
doing fourier basis you already have a
good
uh right inductive bias you don't need
to learn that basis right so you can
learn a few coefficients in that basis
yeah so these are i think some promising
results but i do see lots of avenues
where
we can do both continuous time control
and state estimation in robotic systems
and these methods i think can be very
helpful there
so there have been many other
scenarios where we have used these fno
not in the robotics context but for
different modeling like
being able to predict stress in
materials uh which you know ultimately
for manipulation of deformable objects
this is useful right so there i think uh
can be uh nice use cases there uh but
also right like ultrasound imaging
lithography modeling
so lots of scenarios where you know you
could have a partial differential
equation system but it could also be
just
data right so you don't need to know the
pde system in and if you have both you
can also combine both of them what we
call a physics inform neural operator
you can also
do the hybrid modeling and so that's a
nice flexibility these methods have
there's also a nice connection with
transformers where you know we here we
coined it the foundation models right so
there is a lot of excitement and indeed
a lot of uh you know
computer vision we in addition to
language also computer vision we see a
lot of good challenging cases are
handled well with transformers
because of their again much more global
correlations right compared to cnns with
much you know very small receptive
fields and so there is a nice connection
because you can think of transformers or
special cases of neural operators
because the attention mechanism if you
you know
take it from a fixed
uh sized matrices to
write a continuous generalization that
is an integration with a kernel
so with this viewpoint what you can
think of is the spatial token mixing you
do in transformers
you could solve it through the fourier
transform right so you can
essentially make self attention more
efficient
by learning the weights in the frequency
domain
so that's what here you can see the fno
as learning the full weights but we can
also make it more parameter efficient
and we had like some block diagonal and
other assumptions that
make it scalable to
even much larger models
so we have the ability to capture the
same
right kind of
quality as the full self attention but
be much more efficient in terms of flops
because the full self-attention is
quadratic in complexity and now with the
use of fast fourier transform we can do
it in
linear time and still capture this
effectively
yeah so recently we scaled this up
to create a weather
model a global weather model so you can
see here the ground truth and
the forecast net our model being
overlaid and being able to
accurately predict these atmospheric
rivers uh which are very important for
rainfall prediction which as we know in
california
is a critical aspect um so in addition
we can do right all the extreme weather
predictions um cyclones hurricanes and
we can do it as well as the standard
numerical models the current weather
models that are running for several days
but be
tens of thousands of times faster than
those models um so with this you know we
can
now
do
a large number of ensembles right you
can have like because you have such fast
inference time uh you can create good
ensembles and get good uncertainty
estimates
and do effective weather prediction
yeah so this is one we've been
really excited about the possibility to
you know combine it with data
assimilation and take that and
ultimately be able to replace the
numerical methods that are learned today
any questions here
yeah so all these capabilities uh we are
building it nvidia into a framework
called modulus
so you have these models available with
you know fast gpu acceleration like
really good documentation easy to use
guides so i encourage you to go check
that out if you're doing any kind of
numerical methods for scientific
modeling i think uh this toolbox could
be really helpful for you and it's
now also in pytorch in addition to
tensorflow so if i think
it makes it very flexible to use in a
number of applications
yeah so
you know that was one aspect that i
think
right what machine learning can bring to
robotics
the ability to
capture
both physics
and data-driven methods together
and do that
in this
function space domain rather than in a
discretization
so you're getting better generalization
and
the ability to also run it much faster
than standard pde solvers which
you know especially for environments
like turbulence uh is not practical to
do it in real time
so now
another aspect of again
coming up with good representations
right is
these operational space models again a a
classical notion in control right so can
we do a transformation of our action
space uh for um
more natural manipulation uh but can we
again make that data driven instead of a
fixed operational space controller like
it's done classically how do we make
that
be adapting online and hence we again
get best of both the worlds we have good
physics priors but we also are data
driven and adaptive
and so you'll see a nice uh combination
here and so that's the
you know collaboration we had in our
team as well as the isaac gym which is
the
simulation environment where we've run
this it is
gpu accelerated and uh right
you can do reinforcement learning at
scale which is very helpful and josiah
who's actually here from stanford who
interned with us
yeah so
you know i'm sure
you all agree that
robot manipulation is challenging
especially if you're you know doing
tasks like pouring right like as you're
pouring the mass is changing so it's
very dynamic
so you know having it to
learn from scratch from reinforcement
learning is nearly impossible there is
right a lot of possibility to explore
and it doesn't get to learn very well
and demonstrations may not always be
effective i mean sometimes it is but
also how to get demonstration data and
bring that in is also a challenge
um and so
you know the uh main idea as i mentioned
is
how do we design the controller right so
we can learn the policy but in
what action space representation uh uh
would that be easy to explore easy to
learn the policy and ultimately easy to
adapt uh to changing conditions
yeah so this operational space
controller is a right classical method
so the idea is these end effector
commands and the compliance gains
you're transforming them into joint
torque space
so becomes
quite natural in terms of exploration
you can do that more effectively in this
space
and especially for contact-rich
environments this is or tasks
this can be effective because you're
directly handling uh these torques
so this is useful but
you know what this also requires is the
knowledge of these mass matrix and these
compensation torques right so
something very much
tight to the task and the environment so
if anything is changing
uh you know for the fixed controller
this becomes inflexible and the
performance degrades
and so our natural question is how we
can make this adaptive right be data
driven and online adapt to residual
changes like have like a residual error
to track and uh
you know update this based on that but
at the same time have like this
operational space representation to
enable good exploration and fast
learning
yeah so we do that as two stages so in
the first stage this task agnostic
pre-training the idea is
right
you know you're
giving it a simple task or some kind of
a nominal task right in this case like
kind of tracing like you know a simple
shape here and then
task specific fine-tuning how do you
then
have it
adapt to a new task
uh and also adapt these mass matrices
and others online
yeah so that's the idea like in the
first stage right it's uh you know you
learned uh both this operational space
controller and the policy together
and so you're learning the dynamics
you're learning uh the rl policy through
ppo standard methods uh but the idea is
uh now you know we're learning it
through these right mass matrices
but now
if you want to fine-tune to a different
um
yeah so
so this operational space controller is
right using learnt mass matrix and
compensation torques
but now with fine-tuning uh we will
further adapt it right so there is now
a way to track the residual errors
right and then ask can i now update my
estimates of these mass matrix and
compensation torques as we go along
um
so it's right i mean if you're always
trying to learn from scratch all these
parameters it's hard so trying to divide
it into two stages in the pre-training
stage you know you have a
nominal estimate of all these parameters
and you also have a nominal policy
and so with that can you quickly adapt
to changes let's say you know in the
right like kind of the task like the
puck you may change we change the
friction we change the mass so if you're
changing this can you quickly adapt
online
yeah and so you can see that with the
path tracing here we first pre-train it
to do the circle you can ask zero shot
without any retraining how well does it
do the tracing so in this example both
even the osc
is reasonably able to do because the
mass isn't changing much online right
but we do see with zero shot it's a bit
more stable
but especially for having it to
you know have a task that is harder we
observe that our fine tuning is much
much faster
compared to a fixed oase because there
it's having
right like the wrong parameters and
hence not able to adapt as well
this is much more pronounced in the cup
pouring task because
right so
you can see whether standard osc doesn't
even learn how to pour
because you know the mass matrix you
want it to be flexible and changing
dynamically rather than a fixed one and
now if you try to pour twice the amount
as in training right
you know our model still somewhat does
it zero short but with fine-tuning it is
better
and so this aspect of i think adaptivity
but at the same time having good
pre-training to
learn a good nominal model is a good one
and same with puck pushing as well if we
change the mass and the friction
we see it adapt much better
yeah so you have more details here and
you know it's uh as i said uh done in
isaac gym and this is available online
so i think this is something that you
can build up
further as well um yeah so i mean to me
the main takeaway is if you're trying to
do reinforcement learning in these
challenging cases it needs a lot of data
and even if you do that as free training
with extensive training you wouldn't
still need online adaptation because
we're constantly changing our tasks uh
we're changing environmental conditions
you know here we still didn't do seem to
real but if you were to take it to the
real world there would always be some
changes in specification right like
these kind of mass matrix torques you
know you can never perfectly describe
the friction you can never perfectly
describe
so i think these aspects of having
enough flexibility to online adapt
but learn good nominal models is a good
balance
any questions here
when you were uh kind of adding this
representation of the masters on did you
use any like as an engineer did you use
physics informed approach to be like we
know the situation decomposes like this
or was it the black box kind of approach
um i mean so it is physics informed in
the sense we know how the oac handles
the mass matrix and those right so
that's kind of from the operational
space
transform uh but yeah but the you know
learning the mass matrix and everything
we just kept it flexible because there
we don't want to impose it because you
know we want the flexibility that it
also adapts to changing conditions
great um so in the i guess i have like
another 15 minutes is that
um yeah so you know that was one example
of uh right uh you know having good uh
reinforcement learning principles and
doing that in simulation but if we have
many others
these are legged robots uh this is from
uh almost a couple of years ago now
where we showed in simulation you can
have this legged robot do all kinds of
tasks
and uh directly do seem to real by doing
it as hierarchical reinforcement
learning um and so i think having like
you know there's a lot of open problems
here on how to design good curriculum in
simulations right what is that you know
right set and how to do a good symptom
real transfer
we've also been doing that in the realm
of robotic surgery with collaboration
with andrew hung who is a robotic
surgeon at usc
and
there
simulations are used to in fact train
surgeons so we can ask how we can assess
skills in surgery and also there are
live surgery videos right how we can
kind of correlate the skills across
these different ones um so i think you
know starting with like kind of good
computer vision models to do gesture
recognition and then
be able to assist that i think is a good
first step but ultimately we can also
ask about
reinforcement learning and with that you
know give real-time feedback to surgeons
to say if there are some corrective
measures based on the
trajectory they are taking uh during
surgery so i think there are a lot of
interesting and open problems in these
areas um so i encourage you to check out
isaac jim if you haven't done already
because i believe you know we can do
these uh now reinforcement learning at
scale i think the
earlier the oscar we did that over
thousands of agents
right so this is not something otherwise
would be possible um so having both the
physics everything done on gpu as well
as uh reinforcement learning makes it
very effective and easy to scale
yeah so in the last part uh this is more
computer vision but i believe are really
important for robotics so i you know
want to present some of the latest
advances we've made indeed
foundation models have been
you know really getting big but also
multimodal right so and how do we make
sure they're robust they can do
compositional understanding well and and
what are the right self-supervised
learning losses to enable them to do so
and this becomes very important
because
you know these are large models but we
also want them to have good
representations for many tasks and so
now you know we're seeing
self-supervised learning even beat
supervised learning on many tasks and
that is very promising
and the visual reasoning is like kind of
as i mentioned in the beginning the
system two aspect of it right and how do
we
build that into these models do we need
explicit simple grounding or can we do
that implicitly but what are again some
good self-supervised learning losses to
encourage better
reasoning
so i think
you know that's a broad brush
but these are some concrete works that
are advancing these questions
so for instance the disco box that
appeared last year at iccb
what we are able to do
is use only bounding box supervision so
the only annotations you need in
training data or these bounding boxes
but you can directly get the instant
segmentation and correspondences from
that in a self-supervised manner
and so you can see here from
the uh
right so with bounding box you it turns
it into segmentation masks very
accurately um so this is a random
youtube video not the you know from the
training data set and it's able to do it
well
um
so yeah so we i think these kind of
methods can be very effective because
you know getting segmentation annotation
is so much more expensive than getting
bounding boxes
um and so it's a good intermediate step
before going to fully right unsupervised
learning
so as i mentioned the other aspect is
also designing good
transformer models for
tasks beyond just classification so
segmentation
our sec former model is lightweight but
also can do zero short robustness very
well
so you can see here this
corruptions were not present during
training but it's still able to handle
that pretty well and get good
segmentation and i should mention in
both of these they're not video based
models right they're just frame by frame
but still you see good consistency so
even without enforcing any uh so that
shows the promise but obviously we can
also add temporal consistency to further
enhance these results
and so at nvidia we are building the
disco box into the av stack
to
right like remove the need for
segmentation masks so it's about a few
thousand times faster than how humans
can annotate right because we do have
human annotators we can like
look at the time comparison and see that
you know it's a huge reduction
in those efforts so this is an ongoing
effort
with the av team you know by jose
alvarez and so we're very excited about
this
um yeah so as a next step
you know we what we did this is
appearing in cvpr is to also remove
those requirements for bounding boxes so
this is based on the solo backbone if
you know uh but the main idea is we can
iteratively refine like coarse masks so
there's a coarse mask proposal you can
get from the attention layers but with
self-supervised learning we can refine
them and we can
make that into you know really good
segmentation masks so i think these are
results that are promising because if we
can completely do away with supervision
for uh
intensive tasks like segmentation
i think uh you know that can be very
helpful
in a number of scenarios
so those are right still vision problems
we haven't taken them to
right action and robotics uh but this
one uh right takes it uh all the way in
the sense we want to do manipulation of
these deformable objects so this is an
omniverse
the nvidia platform for uh universal
right like visualization
so what you see here is the ability to
manipulate like if we say this is the
start state this is the target state we
want uh
this uh plush toy to be in
we can learn
the model of like you know
how it is going to deform and learn to
manipulate
and so i'm not giving the details here
but we are using like implicit
representations for correspondences
occupancy
the flow field so a lot of like you know
the recent advances in implicit models
right for uh
geometric understanding uh
we can use that and with that also get
good man ability to manipulate
deformable objects which is more
challenging than rigid about rigid body
um so yeah so i think those are
some useful aspects on adding structure
the other is also creating good
benchmarks you know how do we
uh have the ability to
measure generalization right so and this
bongard hoi which will appear in
cvpr what we are saying is let's create
good benchmarks for systematic
generalization
uh so
here it's a few short learning uh
benchmark where
you know as you see there is like a set
a right there's one set another set and
we want to ask does the query belong to
set a or set b
so what do you think is
different in these two sets what is the
underlying concept
i guess like set a seems to be a lot
more like
people like racing bikes yeah whereas
like set b just tends to be like
pictures of likes and like more general
applications exactly
right so it's like you know we're trying
to give challenging
binary classification problems using
only a few examples
because it's very easy to cheat in a lot
of these action recognition data sets
because you know if like most of the
time like the person is riding the bike
right just the
you know presence of a bike already
signals the
relationship with the bike so what we
want to do is disentangle just the
object recognition from relational
reasoning and so with this data set we
are able to write create these kind of
careful hard negative examples where we
still have the objects but their
relationship changes and so this you
know we did it on the existing i think
it's called the hake data set but it
required a lot of human curation because
there were a lot of like false right
both positives and negatives so it shows
many of the benchmarks we have are quite
noisy
and so it's important to right think
about these kind of challenging uh
ways to test machine learning methods
because we are
you know
it is not easy to cheat on this and we
do see that like we can ask human
annotators and they can very easily
still figure out these relationships
right but even state-of-the-art models
have quite a bit gap from what humans
can do um yeah so this is more as a
challenge than a solution we you know if
you can solve you know if you have good
few short and these capabilities i
encourage you to try out this data set
and i think uh yeah there is the aspect
of how we can do the relational modeling
better
so related to this relational modeling
um what we call a relational
you know reasoning with uh vision
transformer or relvit this will appear
in iclear
i think you know it's important to think
about good self-supervised learning
methods that encourage
this relational reasoning and so this is
something we built explicitly into right
like frameworks like dino that's an
existing backbone but the main principle
here is to you know think of like
learning a dictionary of what are the
features corresponding to different
concepts
right and so that way like the concept
of riding a horse can we dynamically
change that feature set
and be able to better learn
a model for reasoning
yeah so we are getting promising results
on benchmarks but i would say this is
still a
work very much in progress in terms of
how to do uh good relational reasoning
um but yeah i think
you know the power of self-supervised
learning with
good benchmarks
and right like thinking of both local
and global
ways to enforce self-supervised learning
and consistency for relational reasoning
can be very effective
yeah so that was a
right i gave like kind of a few snippets
i'm sorry if that was very fast you know
i didn't dive into those methods but i
do think some of these latest advances
in vision with self-supervised learning
these robust
foundational models more reasoning based
models it could be very
useful for robotics so i look forward to
seeing lots of works
bringing these together
yeah so as a conclusion i think
right i
hopefully convinced you there's a lot of
exciting uh
foundational aspects of machine learning
that are very relevant to robotics
and
the ability to capture
scientific uh phenomena like fluid flow
that is multi-scale potentially chaotic
using good machine learning emulators
that can
transfer across resolutions that are
much faster than what traditional
methods can do
is very promising
and in the same realm like you know
using our right like all the knowledge
from control theory
i feel like we should very much
focus on how to exploit that well but
do
you know little of learning like how do
you kind of think about residuals or
add learning in a lightweight manner to
adapt it quickly i think can uh pay off
a lot and uh you know we really need
this
intersection right like a lot of
reinforcement learning on games has been
from scratch or without much inductive
bias
whereas in robotics
that wouldn't fly we have to very much
start from a i believe from a controls
perspective
but kind of debate where learning should
be added how flexible should the models
be and as much as possible bacon and the
physics and the
inductive bias
as possible
and i do think the simulations
are crucial to exploring this uh at
scale
because you know we can change
environments we can change tasks much
more easily and seem to real i would say
is still very much open especially if
you want in the real world in the wild
for it to adapt very quickly once we
train it in simulation
and lastly you know this aspect of
compositional ai
foundation models i think are the future
at least that's
the only one we have so far and that
power of large-scale pre-training you
know with web scale data is very
promising
but it remains an open question of how
do we turn that into robust
right
compositional reasoning how do we have
zero shot robustness to different kinds
of corruptions and have stability and
safety guarantees i think all these are
still open but
i do think there's a lot to be explored
there thank you
[Applause]
any questions we have a few minutes
yeah so
i guess just for an example let's say
working on
yeah i guess just for example let's say
you're working on something like prep
receptive motors for a better locomotion
and let's say i want to use like symptom
reel so given the current state of like
the field of symptom real like what are
some of
what are examples like some more like
open problems and like
you know that like if they are solved
would make like the field a lot better
yeah so in a lot of the sim to real
tends to work as hierarchical
reinforcement learning right so you've
spent a lot of time debating what is the
level of abstraction you want so in the
legged robotics case that i showed you
know we all we were like saying there's
a dictionary of movements there's walk
there i mean there's like kind of i
guess step there is trout so and they do
that at different speeds so there is
like you need a basis essentially of
primitive actions and so that we all
need like also in the real world the
robot to be able to do that well right
so under that assumption what the
reinforcement learning is doing is
learning how to compose these primitive
actions but in so many examples that is
also hard to come by for instance on
cassie the bipedal robot which we are
now exploring it in simulation you know
getting like right nominal controllers
is hard enough like if you ask it to you
know walk even that under different
friction is hard i mean right you
you can you know no one knows how to
make it jump
so you know there's still a lot of hand
engineering needed and that's a good
start when we can do it
but in many cases we don't know how to
come up with those
right primitive actions and the right
controllers for that
and sometimes it may not even be the
right level of abstraction right
depending on the task so i would say
that's an important open problem
a good question so when you were saying
that with the fourier neural operator
method you were obtaining 1000x speedups
with respect to full blown pda solvers
you were comparing with respect to
full-blown pde solvers or with respect
to reduce order model type of approaches
oh yes uh so these are a lot of those
are like pseudo spectral solvers so in
that sense they're right
they consider like the efficient
implementation for that
setting uh have you also considered or
you know there is a community that
leverages basically projection-based
methods to dramatically reduce the
dimensionality deployment to something
that can be actually solved quite
quickly so i was wondering whether you
also made a comparison to those methods
like ecs w indication in the linear
setting and so on yeah that's a good
point so in a way these pseudo spectral
solvers are like kind of doing reduction
in the fourier domain right so that's
one
class so we mostly like kind of write
the uh or collaborators in the domain
like what they think are the current
practice for different domains for
instance for the pde observer there's
like prescribed time there's different
right kinds of state estimation within
that so we so we basically like kind of
use their guidance in terms of what they
consider as state of the art and
assuming that the solution
uh provided by the full-blown pde
solvers can be considered the ground
truth
what did you see as accuracy gaps
um so not much these were like kind of
right like kind of
either 10 to the minus 2 10 to the minus
3
kind of realm so it so depends on the
application right and that's also the
other aspect in so many of the
applications there are modeling errors
that are much bigger
than these so we may not whereas the
standard approach has been to go to very
low errors with standard solvers and
there you have to do that because unless
you do fine-scale
discretization
you will get very wrong answers right it
doesn't converge whereas with i think
the machine learning methods you can get
away
with higher errors because anyway these
are assumed models in real world
applications in fact with the weather
setting we assume no physics right now
right it's completely data driven
and it's able to in fact many times beat
the noaa the standard forecast estimates
for hurricanes and other
uh models so i think that shows that
maybe
right sometimes if you have enough data
like in the case of the weather we do
maybe dropping some of the modeling
assumptions and seeing what a purely
data-driven method can do
is a good start does it outperform the
newer model across all the scales or
there are regimes like you know in the
short horizon what one model is better
than the other one
um so
i would say like you know these are like
working similar to those models in terms
of like say you know there's acc there
are like extreme right events
percentiles we can compare those uh up
to like about four to five days for you
know for precipitation and other
variables that's considered very
challenging so after that we are seeing
a deviation and i do think there we need
to impose more physics right because for
the longer term
you know you have more chaotic behavior
so so we need that and that's something
we plan to pursue further
all right i think we have time for one
more question if any
if not let's thank again the speaker
thank you
[Applause]